hey it's technology tuesday and i'm
going to be doing another website review
as one of my fiverr gigs today i'm doing
a review of bettinggods.com
from darren so we're going to check out
the site get some advice and see what we
can see
so when it loads up follow the masters
of betting to a higher level view the
tipsters visit the blog tips advise
strike rate return on capital monthly
profit so it looks like just given
advice from tipsters on how to be better
at betting
this is fairly easy to understand it's a
fairly clean website i like it what i
would still like to see is maybe
something a little more powerful you
know one of the biggest urges needs and
desires of bettors and how can you tap
into that with a more emotional picture
at the top i love the clarity that's
great you know the grass i guess relates
to horse racing um maybe some other
sports but i love to see a little bit
more of an emotional picture
at the front where if i'm a better i'm
not a gambler but if i was and i came
and i saw this i would uh be instantly
hooked so i want to put that on there
betting gods the social connection
platform between amateur bettors and
professional bedding tipsters connecting
you with professional tipsters who offer
their advice and tips on a subscription
basis
this is great it's a lot of text i'd
love to see this in a picture right so
you have
uh the picture of the
the better and you know the picture of
the the tipster and maybe it's like
before after the tipster you know happy
person not happy person or winning and
not winning
something visual make it a lot easier to
understand and just quicker to digest
than reading text but i mean it's very
clear i just think it could be made
better
7 000 pounds total winnings total member
winnings um
that seems like a low number i mean
maybe it's a new site um
but you may want to
limit that or hide that until you have
something a little bit higher just so
somebody comes they think oh this site
is established
feature tipsters so here are the people
uh
you know i'd love to see who these
people are not just a picture of a horse
but
the actual person who is this tipster
that's giving their
recommendations is it anonymous at least
telling me a little bit about that
person
instead of just having a stock
photography picture
reviews and testimonials great
strive to be open and transparent great
huge thing in the betting industry
reviews um so it's great i mean i'd love
to be able to click on these reviews i'm
clicking and i can't get to anything and
it says testimonials so i'd love to see
some testimonials that say hey i use
betting gods and
and you know it was great so some kind
of testimonial there would be would
would add a lot of credibility to it too
let's explore the site so this tipster's
button uh is
orange so it should be important and
it's highlighted with football and horse
racing so let's see what we got in here
master racing tipster regular profitable
women's bets
okay so these are the tipsters i can
subscribe to
and here are here's how much it costs so
i'm going to view this tipster let me
see what happens when i load this
and review this tipster
okay we got a trial offer
every month so tells me about this
person a little bit more what they're
doing by month
cool you know what
i'd love to see this be made a little
bit more personal that's what that's the
issue i'm having it and i guess from the
looks of it you don't want to say who
this person is maybe it's a security
issue
um you know somebody finds them and you
know threatens them because they lost
the bet using their tips but
you know maybe a silhouette picture and
and then you have a um
audio recording of them saying hey it's
tipsterjoe and i'm here every wednesday
and i give you horse racing tips you
know just something to make it a little
more personal than than just having a a
picture because the more personal you
can make it the more i can feel
connected to tipster joe
then the more like i'm going to want to
sign up and so that would go across
all of these
but it's interesting to be able to see
each individual tipster and and their
success
so their return on capital and you being
open and transparent about all of that
it's a really i mean the layout overall
clean easy to understand
um
so even that's how it works for you like
this could be on the home page
but uh
more visual like pictures in each one of
these
if you only if you only join one tipster
make it this one joe
skinner so i mean this would be great
who's joe skinner let me see his picture
um
is he actually referring to this tipster
so if you had names for them tipster joe
horseman or whatever it is
it just adds the personality to it and
then the testimonials become more
powerful as well
but overall clean layout easy to
understand what they do
let's uh explore some more so we'll
close that
let's click on free tips
so grab your free horse racing tips and
free football tips today enter your
email address we have a newsletter page
this is great um i love to see a picture
on here somewhere
so it's not just a full
text page to make it easier for people
to sign up it'd be great to have some
kind of bonus on here as well so by
signing up you just you don't just get
the free tips but you also get
a free pdf of the 10 things that you
need to look out for when you're making
bets on football or or horse racing or
whatever it is so i feel like i'm
getting value right up front and you can
show me a picture of that pdf that i'm
gonna download i think it'll really
increase your your conversion rates have
we not in there
and then for this the tips so i'm
getting horse racing and football tips
i don't know how many people are
into both i think people are either
horse racing or football and there
wouldn't be a huge crossover although
i'm sure there are some
people so i'd love to know
the the breakdown like
what do i get in here versus going to
the paid one so i can understand the
benefit i'm gonna do from getting the
paid one
and just maybe showing a sample of what
i'm going to get maybe showing what you
sent out last week just so i kind of get
an understanding of what i'm signing up
for
i'm just skeptical of this so it'd be
great to see some examples and and have
that kind of white paper or free
download so it you i think you'd
dramatically see an increase in your
conversions if you could do those things
let's uh let's look for more let's look
at contact us
what do i get when i contact us
easiest way to get in touch is from the
corn from the form below you can email
us directly at darren at betting gods
okay so darren darren is the one who
ordered this too darren
um darren i'd love to see you on here a
little bit like tell me what your
background is why you started this
you're making a really
um
strong effort to be open and transparent
and showing the numbers and i think
that's great i think that lends a lot of
trust a lot of credibility what would
take it even the next step up is to
share your story and your your picture
you know your smiling mug up on there
because it makes me feel like i can
connect to
the business
and it makes it even more open and
transparent like why did you start this
business why is it important to you what
are you hoping to accomplish with it you
know are you super accessible if
somebody has a question if you said hey
you know email me i really want to hear
from you you make it personal like that
then it adds so much more transparency
and openness and really cultivates that
feeling of trust that i feel like you're
trying to get out with this site and
does a good job of so far
and then it's also great and maybe as
one final thing to to mention gam care
and gamble aware and and these i think
are sites for people who have addiction
problems if i'm not mistaken yeah so gam
care provides support information advice
to people suffering the gambling problem
and gamma wears helping you gamble
responsibly and you know what just
having those links on your site
even if it's in the footer
shows that you're someone who cares
about
people gambling responsibly i don't know
if that's mandated if that has to be on
there or or not um but it's something
you can even leave in the story right
like i want you to gamble responsibly i
love i love football i love horse racing
um
but make sure you do it in a responsible
manner like telling that story adds so
much more crust and open trust and
openness that i think will help
people convert a lot better and want to
refer your site to other people
so that's the review um nine minutes in
let me know what you guys think you like
this video leave a comment you like the
do you want to see more like this you
can subscribe to the channel and uh i
will see everybody soon